scouring through the rubble plowing
through volcanic debris that has now
begun to harden the hope that these
rescue workers might find survivors is
diminishing by the hour
even for the lifeless bodies recover
beneath the rubble a sense of relief
among emergency crews
thank god we found the bodies of these
victims and retrieved them
answers for loved ones in this moment
are better than no news
those who survived are still coming to
terms with their ordeal
at first i thought it was a bomb
explosion and all of the sudden it was
samaro erupting and spooning volcanic
ashes
suddenly it was all dark like it was
going to destroy the earth my children
were scattered around my husband was not
found and i was waiting for him and then
we fled to the evacuation camp
java's largest volcano unleashed a
thunderous plume of ash high into the
sky on saturday raining down on
thousands of panicked people below and
swallowing up entire communities in its
path
mount samiru spewed more ash on monday
forcing rescue teams to retreat in their
search for survivors
waterways around the volcano polluted
with ash now appearing as streams of
dark sludge
and with more rain on the forecast
there's a chance a new river of hot lava
could spew further affecting rescue
operations
images from above show the scale of the
devastation
down below desperate people salvaging
all they can from their wrecked homes
indonesian authorities have advised
locals not to travel within range of
samir's crater
many of the survivors in hospital have
severe burns some with up to 80 percent
of their bodies burned
most people are complaining about having
difficulty breathing and feeling dizzy
some of them have medical histories like
hypertension
with not enough space to treat the
injured families pack makeshift shelters
as they wait to hear from relatives
while at the volcano's observatory
officials are searching for any sign of
new activity and sending out warnings
the status of mount samara is still at
level two which means that at this level
the people need to be more vigilant
because the potential threat is still
there
but many people still wonder why they
weren't warned early enough before
saturday's devastation
jillian wolf al jazeera